- The two-way table of column
relative frequencies below
shows data on gender and voting
preferences during the 2012
United States presidential election.
They give us all this data.
They give us this, as they
say, the two-way table
of column relative frequencies.
So for example this column
right over here is Men.
The column total is 1.00, or
you could say 100 percent.
And we can see that 0.42
of the Men or 42 percent
of the Men voted for Obama.
We can see 52% of the
Men or 0.52 of the Men
voted for Romney.
And we can see that the
Other, neither Obama,
6 percent went for
neither Obama nor Romney.
And for Women, 52 percent went for Obama,
43 percent went for Romney and 5 percent
went for Other.
And then these, this 52 plus 43 plus 5
will add up to 100 percent of the women.
During the 2012 United
States presidential election,
were male voters more
likely to vote for Romney
than female voters?
So let's see.
If we, there are a
couple of ways you could
think about it.
Well, actually, let's go this way.
Male voters, if you were
a man, 52 percent of them
voted for Romney.
While for the Women, 43 percent
of them voted for Romney.
So a man was more likely.
If you randomly picked a
man who voted, there was
a 52 percent chance they voted for Romney,
while if you randomly picked a woman,
there was a 43 percent,
of women who voted,
there was a 43 percent chance
that she voted for Romney.
So yes, male voters
were more likely to vote
for Romney than female voters.
So the answer is Yes.
And we're done.